Absolutely crazy news broke yesterday, former
White House chief strategist to Donald Trump,
Steve Bannon, was arrested and indicted on
multiple charges for defrauding thousands
of donors through those crazy bill.
We build the wall initiatives that he was
a part of.
And it was Bannon and three other people indicted
in a federal investigation in the southern
district of New York.
What prosecutors say went down is that Bannon
and three others defrauded donors by raising
more than 25 million bucks to build a wall
along the southern border of the United States
and that a bunch of the money was used for
personal gain there.
There are so many stories here.
Remember when this was happening, when there
was this idea that, hey, if Trump can't get
the money from the Libs or the Dems, then
we'll just raise the money privately.
Turns out that Steve Bannon was involved in
one of those schemes at the time.
I said, who's stupid enough to donate to this
to think that this is a project that individuals
can actually do?
And if they did donate to it, is it so stupid
that they deserve what's coming to them, which
is to lose their money?
But clearly, this is a scam.
And we were right.
But the scam is one that Steve Bannon is involved
in to the tune of 25 million dollars.
The other people indicted in CRU include that
guy, Brian Cole Fidge, who's the guy we reported
on when this money was actually being raised.
And of course, now the distancing with Steve
Bannon by some will start.
Trump, I'm sure, will say this is very unfair.
These were people looking to do something
that the Dems didn't want to do.
They were doing a good thing, raising money
for the wall, of course.
That's not what's at what's at issue.
What's at issue is that it is was allegedly
a money laundering wire fraud scheme.
And there was this funny picture over the
weekend of Steve Bannon being interviewed
on Fox News and looking really haggard.
And a lot of people were laughing about it
and commenting on it.
Maybe he knew this was coming and that's why
his appearance was so bizarre and outrageous.
And federal prosecutors have a lot of details
here.
They say that when donors were donating to
this project, they were assured 100 percent
of the money raised will go to build the wall.
And I could tell that wasn't true.
Many of you could tell that wasn't true.
Anybody with any common sense could tell they're
not using 25 million to build the wall.
People started writing to Brian Cole Fidge
and then it started to get weird.
And then it turns out that these guys were
profiting from this, profiting from an attack.
And again, I sort of said, if you donate to
this, you're so stupid, you deserve to lose
your money.
Still, criminal criminality is alleged here.
And so if there are criminals and they can
be proven to be criminals, they should be
prosecuted.
Morally, maybe there's a different argument
to be made, but certainly there should be
prosecution.
And we're talking about these individuals
taking hundreds of thousands of dollars from
the donations, essentially creating really
like their own slush fund, in a sense.
And now the PR will start and now we are going
to see this turned into yet another one of
these political witch hunts, as many claim
that the Trump investigations have been in
the Trump impeachment have been.
But don't be confused.
If it smells like a duck and it walks like
a duck and it sounds like a duck.
It's often a duck or someone pretending to
be a duck.
And in this case, this was all of the above
and more to sort of go to the end of the analogies
and metaphors.
But is anybody, if anybody, is truly surprised
by this?
I would be shocked.
But that's the latest.
Steve Bannon indicted.
Are we going to hear Bannon?
I don't remember Bannon.
Was he like an intern maybe for a brief period
in 2015?
No.
This guy was on the National Security Council
at one point, or at least he sat in the meetings.
This is serious and they're going to pretend
it's not.
But
this
is absolutely outrageous.